there's an awful lot at stake in Port
Talbot a place that relies on smooth
trade the global giant Tata Steel
employs four thousand people here and a
No Deal brexit could put all that in
doubt without a free trade deal all of
the steel plants UK customers in the car
and aviation spare parts chain would
become uncompetitive frozen out of the
EU demand for steel could plummet and
the hopes of this town along with it the
draft agreement proposed buys time two
years until a long term trade agreement
can be reached
Chris James works for Tata Steel he's
also a local labour councillor and voted
to remain so did Tony Taylor a steel
worker for more than 40 years
I loved the circle through because in
two weeks time if this gets what we've
done with Parliament we've definitely
had in torrance without hard brexit than
nobody wants such as I wasn't you could
argue the deserve it because they vote
against but this community that's got to
be protected at all cost we still of it
new passports that's what they want it
passports Port Talbot remember voted to
leave the EU
despite benefiting from millions in EU
support Stephen Garvey sells carpets he
buys a lot of stock from Europe but he
sticks by his decision to vote leave I
would hope that in a few years time
we're all looking back at this time in
our lives and thinking a deal was done
and it suited both sides and that's what
I think a deal has to be done that silk
both sides and somebody clever will come
up with this deal and our self-assembly
devoted to leave will say yeah that's
about the best deal we forgot I'll
hopefully somebody I want to disable say
yeah that's a good deal but it's going
to be suddenly far cleverer than me
that's going to decide that they've
lived with uncertainty here for decades
now any deal is seen as better than no
deal at all Nick Martin Sky News but
Talbot
in the city that gave the world Titanic
they were watching as cabinet ministers
abandoned ship but political uncertainty
over brexit is doing nothing for tourism
in Northern Ireland over coffee in the
room where they first received news that
the ship was going down Janice Galt who
represents hotel expressed her concern
that there could be a fawn from
producing ships here to producing
world-class television shows like Game
of Thrones but shipyard and Aerospace
Workers say it's time to end the
political drama by calling a general
election there's only one way of
resolving this here and that's to get
big level we're not talking about a
referendum we're talking about a vote on
a general election let's get a
government under place that the people
actually support and can move forward
with and give their full support
whatever way we come out of brags it
people here are well used to difficult
political negotiations for them brags it
was never just about the economy but
also the constitutional impact what
would it mean for Northern Ireland's
place in the United Kingdom so no one in
Belfast is terribly surprised that it's
proven virtually impossible to strike a
balance between those two things there
was always the potential for the
invisible Irish border to become the
political iceberg and despite many
having signed at the alarm
the bragg's adil needed a lifeline on
its maiden voyage
David Blevins Sky News in Belfast
[Applause]
search Scotland brexit support the
chances are you'll end up here in a
country that voted 63% to remain in the
EU Peterhead is a pocket of people who
didn't it was business as usual at the
fish market this morning with one eye on
business unusual for the sir in this
fishing community the brexit vote was
driven by a desire to leave the Common
Fisheries Policy to control access to UK
waters the brexit fear is that the draft
deal doesn't deliver we just want our
industry to be looked after
to take our our waters back the fishing
industry isn't valued in in the British
economy so much so it is we probably
will be still then delivered again 160
miles separates Peter head from
Edinburgh there's distance to in the
politics setting up the Christmas market
here festival organisers have weighed in
on the Brett's at debate before what do
they think now it's upsetting really to
think that in in a city where we throw
open our doors annually to three four
million people to be sending this
message that they're less welcome and
and and it's going to be harder to get
here what about the political fallout in
Scotland it's forced Minister Nicola
Sturgeon says she's in no doubt it
brings India rev to closer firstly I
have no doubt that Scotland will get an
opportunity to choose again on the
question of Independence what do you
think of what you've seen in the past 24
hours
very disturbing I think she's done our
best that I think she would be this
little being stitched up for the EU I'm
quite vehicle just waiting and seeing it
is the shaping of things to come even if
no one's quite sure what shape it will
leave us in James Matthews Sky News
Edinburgh